on Tuesday nearly a full day after
Islamic terrorist Abdul Razak Ali Artin
also not named Bob Smith ran a car into
a group of students and then hopped out
with a butcher's knife and began hacking
away
CNN still can't uncover a motive here's
CNN's headline quote students back in
class at Ohio State investigators
searched for knife attack motive Ohio
Governor John Kasich oh god no please
God no not John Kasich has now announced
quote we may never find out why Artin
committed this act of terrorism I have a
hot lead it is called Facebook here was
arjan's post just before entering into a
personal jihad against Americans quote
in the name of Allah the most merciful
in the most gracious my brothers and
sisters I am sick and tired of stealing
my seeing my fellow Muslim brothers and
sisters being killed and tortured
everywhere seeing my fellow Muslims
being tortured raped and killed in Burma
led to a boiling point I can't take it
anymore Americans stop interfering with
other countries especially the Muslim
Ummah we are not weak we are weak
remember that wait what if you want us
Muslims to stop carrying lone wolf
attacks then make peace with dala in all
sharm make a pact or a treaty with them
where you promise to leave them alone
you and your fellow apostate allies by
Allah we will not let you sleep unless
you give peace to the Muslims you'll not
celebrate or enjoy any holiday stop the
killing of Muslims in Burma by the way
every single Muslim who disapproves of
my action is a sleeper cell waiting for
a signal I am warning you o America and
the message to the Muslims don't listen
to celebrity scholars who sold their
Deen I'm talking about the likes of
Yasser Rafi Omar Suleiman Newman Mufti
and the list goes on the aware of Al
Maghreb Institute listen instead to our
hero Imam Anwar al Awlaki let me let me
ask you this question if the Muhammad
peace and blessings upon him and his
Inaba were here today wouldn't the
Western media call them terrorists to
conclude by Allah I'm willing to use a
billion infidels in retribution I I
can't get it guys how what drove this I
can't we need encyclopedia brown that
must be on the case
let's get him out there on his bicycle
maybe he can uncover a motive in the
great Ohio State stabbing attack I don't
know the clues are just not there I
can't make the connection the hot lead
wasn't so hot the media have decided to
make this about discrimination against
Muslims of course here is CNN again
quote back in August
Ohio State's student-run newspaper
profiled our time as part of its humans
of Ohio State series obviously they took
humans a little too seriously he had
just transferred from Columbus State and
talked about his struggles to find a
place to pray in peace on the large
campus unquote they neglect to mention
that the end of that profile our town
admits he engaged in prayer in the open
with no consequences which is normal as
an Orthodox Jew I pray three times a day
in the mornings I pray with the tallest
which is the prayer shawl and the
tefillin which is the phylacteries you
wrap them around the arm and on the head
I have never been bothered or even
approached while praying in public
everywhere from campuses to airports
this is America the most tolerant
country on planet earth but the media
have to pretend that Artin was a victim
of the West rather than a perpetrator
against it that by the way Springs from
a deep-seated need to cast Western
civilization in the negative light the
media did the same thing after a spate
of attacks in France an enormous series
of stories broke about how friends had
not been tolerant enough toward new
Muslim immigrants you know aside from
giving them welfare and taking them in
and the whole deal because the left's
chief priority in life is equality of
outcome and because of what believes
actions should have no connection with
consequences the left has to connect all
unhappiness and suffering not with
individual decision making or bad
ideology but with the system and the
system is Islamophobic and that must be
why Artin was so upset and went on a
stabby spree or alternatively we may
never know why this Islamic terrorist
self-declared committed an act of
Islamic terrorism you wanna know why
Donald Trump won because of this sort of
crap we all know why art and committed
an act of terrorism it wasn't because of
the lack of gun control or the evils of
income inequality or any other stupid
reason those who purposefully attempt to
obscure the truth suggest it was because
of radical Islam at least Trump will say
the words unlike cowards from both the
left and the right i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
all righty so we have tons to get to
here today
lots of lesson from Twitter fun that
guys Twitter account is just gonna be a
barrel of laughs for the next four years
and he will definitely fill us up with
good Trump bad Trump
for years to come which is very exciting
and again thanks to Brandon Snipes for
the theme on that we'll get to that in
just a second but first we have say
hello to our friends over at Birch gold
if you have not yet bought some gold for
your portfolio now would be a pretty
opportune time
the markets right now are doing really
well which means that at some point in
the future they won't be doing quite as
well now when that happens you're gonna
want to be a little bit diversified in
precious metals Birch gold can ensure
that you get your IRA or 401k in the
precious metals helps sort of hedge
against inflation and bad economic times
gold has never been worth zero it is of
course the universal human commodity and
the universal human standard of currency
the precious metals something that you
should look into investing in and Birch
gold does it really well birchgold.com
slash Ben birchgold.com slash been a
plus rating from the Better Business
Bureau and again you should visit their
sighting at a 16-page free kit and get
all your information ask all your
questions before you invest and then
when you're ready to invest in precious
metals talk to my friends at Birch gold
group of birchgold.com slash Ben
alrighty so let's begin with yesterday's
attack at Ohio State University so as I
say the media have completely gotten it
wrong because this is what they do for a
living there was this interview that
this this attacker did with the lantern
which is an Ohio State University
publication and here's what this
interview said it said humans of Ohio
State and this is a direct quote from
this guy who just wounded 11 people with
a knife after driving car into them
quote I just transferred for Columbus
State we had prayer rooms like actual
rooms where we could go to pray because
we Muslims have to pray 5 times a day
there's Faja which is early in the
morning at dawn then xur during the
daytime
then oskar in the evening like right
about now and in mouth Korea but which
is like right at sunset and then each
eye at night
I wanted to pray ah sir I mean I'm new
here this is my first day this place is
huge and I don't even know where to pray
I wanted to pray in the open but I was
kind of scared with everything going on
in the media I'm a Muslim it's not what
the media portrays me to be if people
look at me a Muslim praying I don't know
what they're gonna think what's gonna
happen but I don't blame them it's the
media that put that picture in their
head so there
gonna have to have it and it's gonna
make them feel uncomfortable I was kind
of scared right now but I just did it I
relied on God I went over to the corner
and just prayed and nothing happened
because no one cares because in America
you can pray however you want and no one
is going to bother you because again
this is America but it does illuminate a
couple of points that are pretty amazing
number one in order for people to
perpetrate acts of violence and terror
they have to feel like they're victims
people like to feel justified in what
they're doing very few know TV makes all
of the bad guys on TV people who are
insanely barbaric and in sadists like if
you watched Game of Thrones you know
that the great villains and Game of
Thrones people like Joffrey Baratheon or
people like Ramsay Bolton these are all
people who revel in other people
suffering and something they enjoy right
they just like cutting parts off of
people and they take a sick sort of
pleasure in it the truth is the vast
majority of people who commit acts of
violence on earth are not sociopathic
sadist they're not people who just sit
around going you know what I'd really
like to do cut a finger off somebody
today the number of people who are like
that is actually very very small in the
human population it's really small
Hollywood likes to build those people up
as their as the real villains the real
villains are always people who just
enjoy the sadism for the sake of the
sadism but that's a really small group
of people most people who do evil things
think they're doing something good right
most people who were participating in
the Holocaust thought that they were
doing something good on behalf of the
fatherland most people who participated
in the mass killings in the Soviet Union
literally people got so tired during the
mass killings in the Soviet Union the
soldiers got so tired from holding their
arm out to shoot people in the head that
they actually had people on staff
masseuses on staff who had massaged the
right arm and trigger-finger of the
people who are pulling the gun because
they were murdering so many thousands of
people at a time in the Soviet Union
those people they thought that they were
heroes they thought they were doing
something good right people always have
to think they're doing something good
there's not a person who's alive who
doesn't have a way to justify their
actions it's just the way the human
brain works in fact Jonathan Hyde who's
a sort of an ethicist and sociologist at
New York University he wrote a whole
book called the righteous mind in which
he discusses the fact that the human
brain is sort of like we tend to think
that the reasonable side of us is what
controls the human brain in reality he
likens the human brain to a rider on an
elephant
the elephant is sort of your instinctive
mind the elephant really tells you where
to go and then the writer can sort of
make small deflections is the path of
the elephant but in the end the elephant
rules that's how human beings really
work we want to do certain things and
then we come up with justifications
later for the things that we're doing
well one of the ways that you justify
killing a bunch of innocent people at
Ohio State University is not because
you're a sadist and you want to watch
people suffer you do it because you
think you're a victim you build up in
your own mind that you are the victim of
an evil evil system that Islamophobia is
targeting you and therefore you are
acting in response right you're always
punching back no one has ever been an
offense an offender no one's ever an
aggressor you're always punching back
bin Laden if you read his his statements
it was always about I'm taking revenge
for acts it was always I'm justified in
doing what I'm doing because I'm
reacting right yeah I didn't start it
you started it and that that's always
what what evil people say that's what
good people say too sometimes but
they're the ones who are telling the
truth
so you have to build up the moment the
idea that you are a victim of
Islamophobia so the Islamic phobia
narrative that was promoted by this guy
is is point number one which is you have
to feel justified in order to kill
innocent people
point number two and this is the part
that's that's truly amazing is that you
know he says in there that the media
portray this really terrible vision of
Muslims and that's why people view me
badly no actually if people view Muslims
badly
it's because people who say that Muslims
ought not to be viewed Adly drive trucks
into groups of people and then stab them
with butcher knives like that that would
probably be it right this guy who's
saying I don't understand why people see
Muslims so badly if they do it's because
of people like you
and we shouldn't paint of course all
Muslims with the bra with the brush of
this terrorist that's silly but it is
worthwhile noting that the same guy
who's complaining about media coverage
of Islam is the guy who drove a truck
into the middle of a group of people and
then started hacking away with a
butcher's knife and then that is worth
noting it is also worth noting that the
Islamophobia narrative is a way to shut
down debate it's a way for people to
simply suggest that you can't have real
questions about how radical Islam works
about the ideology of radical Islam
whether it's promoting violence you just
shout Islamophobia and that ends the
conversation there's this suffix that
the left loves to add to things then in
that suffix is phobia and the reason
they do that is because they want to
suggest that your opposition
to some activity is not rooted in reason
or risk assessment your opposition to
certain activity is rooted instead in an
insane fear of things right so if you
say that men are men and women are women
for example and that men can't magically
become women and women can't magically
become men the response of the left is
not that's scientifically false let me
explain to you how a woman is man
because they can't do that instead their
responses you're a trans folk right
you're transphobic I'm not afraid of
transgender people I don't know a lot of
people who are afraid of friends gender
people I feel horrible for transgender
people but the way that the left act
it's not if you believe this it's not
because in any way you have science to
back you it's because you are a phob
right you fear so if you are concerned
about radical Islam the left's response
is well yeah that's cuz you fear Islam
you have an irrational fear of Islam and
radical Islam first of all fear of
radical Islam is perfectly rational
given the record of radical Islam around
the world to women to gays to people of
civilized nations everywhere to Jews to
Christians there's plenty to fear from
radical Islam obviously but the left
slaps the phobia label on their to label
you pathological for having attitudes
about people based on their own
decision-making process you don't want
to be called pathological you don't want
to be called a weakling who lives in
fear all the time and so instead you say
okay well if I see somebody who is who
may be engaged in something bad I'm not
gonna report it because I don't want
people labeling me in islamaphobe that's
the danger of labeling people phobic
it's the danger of saying that
somebody's pathological there's
something wrong with their brain if they
if they have a risk assessment about
about a people a group of people who
engage with a certain ideology again no
one ever said Nazi phobic right because
Nazism was an evil ideology radical
Islam is an evil ideology not Islam
itself radical Islam now the Islam that
says that honor killings are okay and
that clinic Tamizh are worthwhile and
that Jews ought to be slaughtered behind
the rocks and the trees where they hide
that sort of Islam is absolutely evil
and should be fought and it's not phobic
to say that right no one's Nazi phobic
you just don't like Nazism it's a bad
idea oh gee radical Islam is a bad idea
he not mainstream Islam not mainstream
Islam radical Islam and there is a
distinction westernized Muslims are not
the same as as Muslims who are living in
Afghanistan you
see it by the polling data and one of
the things I don't like to do here on
the bench Shapiro show is get into
textual analysis of the Quran because
I'm significantly more interested in
what people do then in what people feel
right I'm more interested in in behavior
right there's lots of stuff in the Bible
too that's pretty violent but
judeo-christian tradition has basically
read a lot of that stuff as either
obsolete or an applicable to today's
situation and so how people act matters
more to me than what the Bible says you
know in terms of assessing how people
think and act the same thing is true of
Islam if you give me a moderate Muslim I
judge them by behavior not by ideology
the only reason ideology matters is if
the ideology actually produces more
violent people radical Islam does
produce more violent people Nazism
produces more violent people that makes
a difference but I'm not going to sit
here and analyze Quranic verses because
there are a lot of people who interpret
the Quranic verses in a moderate way
which is good and there are a lot of
people who don't which is bad so I'd
rather analyze the philosophy of the
people who are doing the bad things then
try and lump everybody together that's
why I don't bother doing the Quranic
analysis which everyone's capable of
doing and everybody has a different a
different read okay so in other news
from the so hyoe state thing the media
is trying to ignore that islam had
anything to do with that radical islam
had anything to do with it or political
islam more realistically had anything to
do with it instead the media wanted to
jump on the bandwagon about gun control
so here is what as this thing was
unfolding yesterday there were reports
that there was an active shooter at ohio
state and normally when these things
break the information is really really
spotty right you don't know very much
about what's going on because usually
there are several different accounts
those very often they'll say multiple
shooters when it's really just multiple
accounts with the same shooter in this
particular case there was no shooter the
shots that were being heard were from
the cop who killed this this terrorist
bastard so the left couldn't wait they
immediately jumped in their narrative
and they started tweeting here's Tim
Kaine well here Shannon Watts I mean
start Tim Kaine fine
stick there's Tim Kaine the the senator
from Virginia and former vice
presidential candidate deeply saddened
by the senseless act of gun violence at
Ohio State this morning praying for the
injured and the entire Buckeye community
so he's jumping immediately to the gun
control argument right whenever the left
says senseless act of gun violence what
they really mean is let's ban guns
number one it wasn't an act of gun
number two it wouldn't been senseless it
was obviously driven by an ideology an
evil murderous ideology he wasn't the
only one
Shannon watts who was a gun control
leader she tweeted for school shooting
victims it's not too soon to discuss our
nation's lacks gun laws it's too late
Ohio State University except there was
no school shooting at Ohio State
University it was a Muslim terrorist
using a car and a knife and Adam Feldman
who's a theater critic and I know that
when I'm looking for solid political
analysis I always go straight to the
theater critics here is Adam Feldman
what happened at Ohio State is terrible
but math stabber leaves eight people
with non-life-threatening injuries is
why gun control matters first of all we
have no evidence that this guy ever
tried to even apply for a gun he
probably could have gotten one legally
there was nothing to stop him in the
state of Ohio I assume beyond that you
know this is a real strained argument so
it's a no when your outcome is always
the same to your argument there's
something wrong with your argument so if
somebody shoots people that's evidence
that gun control is necessary and if
somebody stabs people that's in that's
evidence that gun control is working
amazing amazing how that operates
according to the left the left had to
jump to their narrative it's it's very
funny the left is talking a lot these
days about fake news this is this big
fake news controversy this idea that
that people were driven to their various
political perspectives by news that that
confirms their bias there's truth to
this but this is an example of how the
left did it right so the reality is
we're always looking for confirmation
bias it's one of the reasons why on this
program I really strive to sort of give
you what I think are the unbiased sets
of facts I make my perspective clear but
I'm gonna tell you the truth whether it
benefits me personally or not right
means during the entire election cycle I
was very critical of Donald Trump that
certainly didn't benefit me in any way
you know when it comes to his presidency
I'm gonna call it like I see it I think
that most people have a tendency to find
a piece of news and then try and fit it
into the puzzle of their thinking so
everybody's everybody's world view has a
set of holes that are to be filled by
pegs every piece of news is a peg if the
peg doesn't fit people try to ram it it
anyway that's exactly what happened with
the left on this story they wanted a
gun-control peg to sticking their gun
control worldview it was a square peg
they tried to shove it in the round hole
anyway and it ends
making them look stupid as well it
should here's my rule we should wait
till all the facts are out this is true
on police shootings it's true on black
lives matter riots it's run all this
stuff okay
you should always wait and I don't
always buy by this role I should I'm
trying to hold myself to a higher
standard on this we should always try to
wait till the facts are out or at least
base our opinions on the best available
facts before we jump to a conclusion
that confirms our worldview that's what
we should do because otherwise we're not
actually analyzing the news we're just
hacks trying to trying to bolster what
we already think about the universe and
that's not really particularly useful to
anybody if you let the evidence lead you
to a conclusion rather than letting your
conclusion lead you to the evidence okay
we're going to have to break there but
we have much more coming up we're going
to deconstruct the culture in a little
while we're also going to talk about
Donald Trump and flag-burning
which is I have sort of interesting take
on it maybe different than some of the
ones you've heard today go to daily wire
calm to become a subscriber eight bucks
a month if you become an annual
subscriber we are still offering the
special deal you get a free copy of my
novel true allegiance signed by yours
truly you can frame it you can keep it
forever handed down to your children one
day say that you received and it's
signed copy or alternatively sell it on
eBay I can't stop you but daily wire
calm is where you go to become a
subscriber and and make sure that that
you you know take advantage of that
because it's it's it is a great service
obviously you get to see the rest of
this show live I get to be part of the
mailbag which we're doing on Thursday
you get to watch Clavin the show live be
part of his mailbag and we have new
goodies coming up all the time for our
subscribers some big ones coming up
actually pretty soon we're excited to
announce so daily wire comm is where you
subscribe go there right now become part
of the largest conservative podcast in
America
you